it's a comedy
[Music]
you just
so after part one a cheesy stylized
action romp that's very much a product
of its time I love it so much man it's
like a vampire huntin John wick mother
awesome and part 2 that delves deeper
into the world-building characters
themes of classism and Prejudice a
beautiful follow up that expands on its
story and narrows its focus
simultaneously for an experience that
has more substance to accommodate the
style blade 2 combines the fun of the
first film with the more focused
expressive and personal touch that del
Toro brings to the screen with a lot of
energy you land on the stunning
conclusion a big lasagna of sadness come
on guys you gave me this one hey man you
said you wanted it so you could do that
joker intro thing I mean I could have
still done that with blade 2 let's not
bring this back up again guys
Xavier you can still do the videogame
instead ok never mind we good this
movie's an interesting case and that it
feels like it had everything going
against it from day one it's a miracle
this thing made it out the door when
every individual aspect of the movie is
so troubled just sit and watch plays
Trinity it's a d-minus but if you know
what they went through to get that movie
made yeah it is an A+ the fact of that
movie exists puts it above Citizen Kane
with all the craziness that went down
every decision was shaky at best every
component that needed more fine-tuning
is rushed to completion with the
mentality of good enough I guess
so let's start with the broad strokes
and focus in on what went wrong time to
set the scene picture this you're a
young screenwriter by the name of David
s Goyer you wrote two of the first
successful comic book films ever but you
need to do it again so you tap out a
script and no funny you should say that
because I was going through some old
videos and this is starting to sound a
bit familiar Oh fine okay we'll go a
third-person david's foyer was tasked
with following up the previous films but
wesley snipes
the face of the whole project
he isn't happy with the script he put
together nor does he like the director
they have picked out who according to my
research might have been Stephen
Norrington the director of the first
film Norrington allegedly passed on it
because he didn't like the script either
blade twos director Guillermo del Toro
was offered the project and said no
because he was more interested in making
Hellboy which is rad Oliver Hirsch but
last name was considered and said no
because of scheduling conflicts
so gore who had no experience directing
a feature film decided to just do it
himself I won't say this is the biggest
mistake made in production but a
first-time director helming a major
sequel has a track record of being iffy
in addition to his inexperience gore was
apparently not popular with blade
himself he tried to strangle the
director one day literally tried to
strangle him Wesley Snipes hated working
with him to the point of refusing to
speak with him directly he even sent his
assistant to do it or just communicate
with sticky-notes communicate with with
post-its that he would give to the
director and each one he would sign
blade he'd refused to shoot some scenes
requiring them to use stand-ins or just
CGI Snipes his face onto a stunt double
it's hard to make your blade movie work
when blade doesn't want to be there he
would you he would only answer to the
name blade you you couldn't follow her
and you'd walk by his trailer and this
wall of a pod stench would just like
whoa and the kind of push you to the
side the starring actor is locking
himself in his trailer to smoke pot all
day because he hates the director so
much resulting in the title character of
the movie having less than a hundred
lines of dialogue most of which are a
single word and barely any screen time
given everything I've learned in film
school and my expert opinion I'd say
that sucks even kris kristofferson the
man behind blades sidekick Whistler said
he wasn't happy with Gloria's script
either because he didn't like how many
new characters it shoved in artificially
to expand the film's universe even the
silly ass alternate ending with Ryan
Reynolds and whistlers daughter fighting
a terrible looking vampire werewolf one
could assume these two were meant to
have some kind of spin-off series that
never went anywhere so let's break down
these two big factors direction and the
script Gore's direction is odd to say
the least a lot of people in Hollywood
think they can direct they take one look
at it and go yeah I could totally handle
that and then shortly after it's clear
they have no idea what they're doing the
pacing and movement of the actors always
feel so clunky the actors themselves
feel like they're cringing at the movie
they're in I was there when they
crucified him like they don't believe
the dialogue they're saying and are just
resigning to act as cartoony as possible
to get some of these words out the
camerawork is a jittery mess and it
never feels like it knows the
appropriate place to be for the scene
they're going for like this emotional
death scene filmed at a completely flat
angle in one continuous shot
when you want to convey emotion
typically the camera is supposed to zoom
in on an actor's most valuable asset for
doing so their faces but blade is just
like awkwardly standing there with no
idea what to do with his arms he looks
like an introverted youtuber trying to
address the audience directly we're also
instructed Jessica Biel to aim for the
camera with her bow and arrow for a
really cool shot resulting in her
shooting it straight through the lens
and cost him to production $300,000 to
replace it she hit a complete bull's-eye
and the arrow embedded itself about six
inches into the camera went through the
lens and we ended up destroying quite a
few cameras over the course of the film
which I guess isn't really a badge of
honor but Dave maybe you should have
told her to aim a little lower the girls
are really damn good shot the action
scenes are far less tight than they used
to be all the slick choreography and
badass martial arts has now toned down
to like slow judo moves where the actors
are just kind of flipping each other
around [ __ ] like this happens a lot then
there's this guy getting kicked and then
they don't know what to do with him so
he just disintegrates the fight
choreography feels noticeably ungraceful
so they try to overcompensate with
faster editing meaning you're seeing
something very stiff and slow with shaky
cam and constant fast cuts from
completely nonsense camera angles to
make it appear faster and more kinetic
than it actually is
I've heard that Guillermo del Toro
studied the work of the director from
the first blade movie to try and make
sure he knew what to do with the visual
style in action scenes there was a sense
of continuity between those two films
while the Goya directed blade feels so
sloppy by comparison on the list of
things that made blade memorable the
sense of style and smoothness was at the
top the guy always made fighting the
hordes of the undead seemed so
effortless but Trinity has his lowest
vampire killcount of the series and he
just doesn't give off the same
superhuman vibe anymore
compare this to any action seen from the
first two movies look at that solid well
planned out choreography with well paced
editing and long camera takes to let you
really see what's going on in detail
just look how differently they film a
sword fight in both films and that's not
to say that vampires are more evenly
matched with him either
they're just as slow and lacking proper
direction as he is what is blade without
the style or the ass-kicking 90s matrix
influence cool factor it's a bad movie
but it's a bad blade movie dude why'd
you have him say that I'm aware that the
photography and action choreography
aren't entirely up to glory but it's his
job as a director to unite all parts of
production and make sure these things
are lining up properly if every
individual part of production is
floundering then you have to acknowledge
that he wasn't entirely ready to handle
all those moving parts at once and all
of those people are shakily synchronized
over the tempo of his script which we've
established no one involved was a fan of
yes you have yes I have look at me and
some of you have it take off the glasses
and tell me if you've done your taxes
you can file them in Texas yeah you know
I've told him just a million times you
can fight the undead but you can't fight
the IRS go get your w-2 go get your
receipts and we're gonna do it right now
one of my teachers in film school once
asked the classic question how can the
rest of a movie improve upon a bad
script and the students around the room
said things like just to have the
performances make the lines more
believable shoot it really well give it
a good soundtrack to make the emotion
land a little more and then he just
stopped us and said the answer is you
can't fix a bad script a bad script is a
bad mood the story of blade Trinity is
that vampires have resurrected Dracula
from his ancient slumber to help him
finally beat the human race once and for
all
to hinder blade they frame him for a
murder so that the human world is now
afraid of him along the way he meets a
new group of young vampire Slayer's that
want to team up and help him defeat the
vampire horde one final time
we know what you are you're a stone-cold
killer and you're sick as [ __ ]
considering the previous two films were
serviceable or pretty good in terms of
writing you have to wonder what changed
why did it get all [ __ ] up this time
it's because this wasn't the idea Gore
wanted to go with either lawyers
original pitch for Blade 3 was a
post-apocalyptic scenario where the
vampires had won and taken over the
world decades in the future with blade
aging slower than he should do to his
vamper ISM and becoming humanity's last
hope
basically like old man blade the studio
turned this down because it sounded too
depressing and then he had to lazily
cobble together a new idea that he
seemed far less invested in thus blade
Trinity is riddled with ideas and
characters introduced only to serve no
purpose and be forgotten about shortly
after the idea of making blade a
fugitive from the law of the human world
was a really cool one but as soon as
they take him in he's saved by Ryan
Reynolds and then it's never really an
issue again throughout the entire movie
he's just running around in broad
daylight coming and going as he pleases
in public places with a [ __ ] samurai
sword on his back and no one calls the
cops
the police are never hot on his trail no
one recognizes him as this public enemy
number one until the ending which is an
awkward mess anyway Snipes was so
disinterested in this scene that they
had to CGI his eyes open because he
wouldn't cooperate then blade awkwardly
beats up a bunch of innocent people and
and and then they took this out with
reshoots and added some voice over to
explain that Dracula pretended to be
blade body to do him a favor I guess I
don't know nobody really knows the
specifics of his origin oh no that
wouldn't have been interesting
information to no [ __ ] that but the slow
walking through the city sequence with
rap music was what made it to the final
edit there's no point in bringing
Whistler back from the dead and Blade 2
only to have killed him off again in a
way less ceremonious way in this one
why aren't you smarter if I was Chris
Christopher's Christianson Kristofferson
Kristen I wouldn't have liked this
direction for my character either and no
one else in the movie seems to mourn or
care in Blade 1 this motivated bleh
to kick-ass more than ever but this time
Whistler dies and he just kind of sleep
walks away from the whole thing and
doesn't seem to think about it too much
this little girl serves no purpose in
the movie except to make us more mad at
Dracula for kidnapping her it's like
they're trying so hard to convince you
that he's a bad guy
because his face and voice don't do it
even seemingly new ideas this movie has
are actually all recycled like this
vampire Final Solution they talk about
is actually a scrapped idea from a scene
in Blade 1 the whole arc of everyone
trying to convince blade that a little
teamwork wouldn't kill him has been done
already and it's undermined by the fact
that he does everything his way and acts
as stubborn as possible and still
succeeds it pretty much everything like
a Hollywood actor Sommerfeld managed to
treatment the cure and now I killed him
just gonna casually brush off that whole
thing about how vampires can be cured
and totally rehabilitated you know a lot
of them are infected against their will
nope let's make a virus that'll wipe
them all out there's so many scenes that
don't have any purpose being there
why does Dracula walk around the city
and try to kill people that try to sell
him vampire sex toys
why does blade have this weird
interaction with his little girl was
that to humanize him the world is nice
did you see was more of an inhuman
weirdo than ever now why do we get some
kind of emotional shower scene with
Abigail remembering her father's words
about not wanting her to be a vampire
hunter clearly he led her be one and it
wasn't a major conflict between them and
it doesn't really play into any kind of
character arc she add there's also a lot
of scenes where they just let Ryan
Reynolds be on and say hilarious
dialogue that doesn't really amount to
anything this movie's a lot of
completely disconnected interchangeable
scenes with occasionally bland action
set-pieces thrown in between long bouts
of stilted dialogue performed by actors
who don't like a script and don't want
to be there filmed and edited in the
most obnoxious and confusing way
possible whoo bad directing bad script
bad pacing bad editing
bad acting this is balls on a film about
the [ __ ] up but maybe just maybe the
cast can kind of save it with their own
natural charisma I feel like they
planned on Hannibal King being a more
popular character than he was they
devote so much screen time to him just
being himself me more of a Don Johnson
family people don't know he recorded an
Ellen Morgan Andrea Bocelli fan he's
blind me I'm more of a Celine Dion fan
she's a Canadian treasure and I've been
calling him Ryan Reynolds so far because
that's what he is
he talks exactly how he does in every
other movie he's allowed to improvise
him juggling Thunder come back wheezing
bag coked-up Oregon Mack the world I
feel like they didn't write him any
dialogue and just hold Ryan on set to do
whatever he felt like so he got his
trademark speech pattern of calling
people super complicated insults or just
casually working in silly references in
the right conditions this can really
work for him what did you take I was
apologizing for I mean there's a list
green lanten are IPV or selfless
terrible late trinity but he refused out
of place with the rest of the movies
grim tone and unlike typical vampires
her fangs are located in their vagina
moving on especially I hate how there's
always these awkward little pauses after
his lines like it's a goddamn sitcom and
they want the audience to catch their
breath before the next side-splitting
zinger and that's basically turning a
frown upside down
I'm sorry I had a lot of sugar today
would you consider doing the full blade
movie and I was wondering would you be
interested to do another one to be back
as Annabel King oh I know as stated
before blades half-asleep sometimes he's
actually asleep Whistler is basically a
blink and you'll miss in cameo and he's
not exactly into his performance either
Patton Oswalt is introduced and has this
hilarious scene have you ever been laid
many times with ladies then is killed
off screen
Katniss Whistler's it's just a complete
flatline doth vampire lady is so campy
that she feels out of place in every
scene this wouldn't be a Marvel movie
without a healthy amount of pointless
studio interference and apparently the
producers love Triple H's screen
presence so much that they had extra
dialogue and scenes added for him so he
could get bangers like this line and
window [ __ ] did you see my dick [ __ ]
and last but not least Lincoln Burrows
himself Dracula he has to be one of the
most horribly miscast villains in a
comic book movie Dracula is typically a
character that we associate with a lot
of sinister charisma he's a manipulator
that has you entranced and subject to
his will his hatred for humanity is held
in such a classy and understated way
he's too good for us mere mortals too
powerful too intelligent he sees
humanity as his weak little playthings
god damned Dracula your fit is trash
Dominic Purcell captures none of this is
Dracula whom they keep calling Drake
because I guess they were too
embarrassed to use Dracula half the time
not that the script is helping him any
but he has none of the presents that a
world ending villain needs he just seems
too well nice careful heard about you
sorry guys this is fighting I can't see
this guy as a heartless villain I just
get the impression that he's a really
chill guy that's trying to be the bad
guy in his 12 year old son's video
project
[Music]
none of this evil dialogue sounds
genuine or believable sacrament
he certainly doesn't look villainous
looks like some kind of hipster pirate
or cabin boy or a hunky guy with frosted
tips in an early mm soap opera not the
Prince of Darkness when he's utilized
well he's a pretty good actor I feel
like he plays better as a conflicted
normal guy who makes the wrong decisions
but still ultimately wants to do the
right thing for a while he was my top
pick to play Venom's so I don't dislike
the guy at all but I just don't get that
villainous vibe from him here and that
causes major problems because he's
presented as the overwhelming ultimate
enemy force for the movie everyone's
emphasizing his strengths and he just
seems like any other random vampire
blade has killed several thousand of
everyone's acting so afraid of this guy
who isn't remotely scary so what do we
have left
poor Direction cast that's either barely
trying or trying too hard action scenes
that feel stiff and unsatisfying story
full of misplaced or rehashed ideas and
a leather trench coat and sunglasses
wearing 90's action style that by this
point was starting to wear thin if it
wasn't done properly this came out after
two x-men movies and two spider-man
movies as many strides as the Blade
series made to bring comic book movies
to the mainstream in the 90s by the mid
2000s it was only repeating itself while
other things innovated and evolved all
these other movies were coming out with
direct adaptations of comics storylines
massive budgets and insane action
had never been visualized in film before
well blades just struggling behind with
more quote unquote original stories full
of the same thing he was doing six years
ago but with a tenth of the enthusiasm
in the comics we have storylines about
shields stealing his blood to make an
army of cloned daywalker super soldiers
and blade hunting necromancer's but we
had yet another sequel have him fighting
over confident edgy vampires that seem
like snotty rich teenagers you never
know what you're gonna get when you make
a movie you never know which
performances are going to pop you things
that that work really well on the
written page just end up working
horribly you know on screen and and and
vice versa at you you have no idea and
so you can think of scene we'll play you
know excellently and when it's cut
together is just flat and dead as a dog
and I mean writing a script is not the
same thing as making a movie everything
that made blades stand out before was
now holding him back and all it took was
one repetitive sequel to cause Hollywood
to forget about him until now god knows
if the MCU can handle a character like
this and how the new version of him will
compare the old one but I'm just happy
that we haven't seen the last of blade
and for now there's a little bit of hope
the bar was set incredibly high but then
incredibly low it probably won't be
r-rated but when the bad guys in the
movie turned to ash and dust when you
stab them instead of your typical gory
mess it doesn't need to be rated R all
they have to do is capture some of that
old spirit of effortless stylized
visceral vampire killing badassery and
it'll at least be better than Trinity
wait which one of us is gonna cover the
spin-off TV show
I'm too busy reviewing the next six
seasons of Titans but saying I will
never watch it again between each video
I can't I'm already putting off like for
retrospective series and making another
three spider-man videos this month while
complaining about being associated with
spider-man did you know there's a moon
night reference in that show
next year they tell me that werewolves
exist my colleague mark spectres area of
expertise well I'm still working on my
video reviews of Avatar The Last
Airbender because those are just so
topical right now so I mean you see the
position I'm in can I do it hello gamers
what about me famous youtuber sliver boy
shut up Scott you're really showing your
true colors behind those monotone voices
you sick bastards how about all three of
you go back to using MCU spider-man four
clicks and views [ __ ] sellout you do
realize that's a copyrighted character
right you're gonna get [ __ ] sued
hello I'm Alex from high top fill your
holes your hole browning is a shoe what
the [ __ ] wrong with you